Stefan ist so schlau und er ist gut im Bett. Du bist so heiss, der Justitivklammteilung macht dich nicht weniger heiss. Falls ihr ein Kind wollt und keinen Samen zur Verfügung habt, schreibt Stefan gerne mal an. Ich hab gefickt, ich hab meine potenten Samen hineingeschleudert. Da wurde gefickt. Masturbation und unnütze Tränen. Oder ist es der Beginn einer wundervollen Love Story? Oh, das war Kuschel. Der wird ja sofort ganz anders. Aber ohne Scherz. Wir sind von Rough Sex. Am Ende sind wir Menschen und wollen uns sexuell entfalten. Und natürlich, deswegen müssen wir heute mal drüber reden. Ja, einen wunderschönen guten Abend, Morgen, Nacht. Ich bin in Stimmung, Stefan. du hast es geschafft. Ich habe auch einen riesen Ständer in der Hose. Stefan, sind wir zu sexuell geworden? Also jetzt mal ernst gemeine Frage, jetzt mal wirklich komplett ernst, weil wir kaum ausserhalb der Folge reden. Wenn das war die komplette Sammlung der Filthy Jokes aus 450 Folgen, das war Best of Sex. Ich glaube, auf die Antwort sind wir zu obszön geworden, kann ich ganz einfach sagen.
Nein, zu wenig. Hier wird zu wenig über Sex gesprochen.
Ich sehe die ganze Zeit bei TikTok, und das mache ich kurz nach voller Begrüßung, ganz kurz zu dir.
Bei TikTok gehen die ganzen Podcasts viral mit ihren Clips über Sex und Hoden und hier steht überall steht diese ganzen Publikumslieblinge da. Aber ist nicht die Zeit des Sexpodcasts? Penisbruch, so Lach-Emojis. Ja, natürlich, das machen wir halt nicht. Wir reden nicht über unsere Sexunfälle. Und du hast mir privat, als die Mikro ausging, viel erzählt. Dann denke ich mir, warum nicht mal viele Unfälle, ich habe nur mal viele Unfälle,
ich war wieder im Krankenhaus, aber ich dachte,
die Zeit der Sexpodcast ist vorbei eigentlich.
Es gab doch mal diese Sexvergnügen,
Mordvergnügen, Sexmord
und so. Warum sind sie vorbei?
Weil die ganzen anderen Podcasts zu
Sexpodcasts geworden sind, schleichen.
Außer wir. Wir reden über
Herr der Ringe und Fluch der Karibik.
Naja, ich muss ja tatsächlich jedes Mal, bei jeder Folge gibt es ja diesen Haken, dass es obszön ist, muss man ja angeben, muss man immer den Haken machen und ich glaube in der gesamten Geschichte des Podcast-Ufos habe ich ein einziges Mal den Explicit-Haken gemacht, in den ersten Hundert irgendwo, weil ich mir dachte, oh, heute wurde es schon ein bisschen schwitzig, heute wurde es schon ein bisschen rutschig. Ich weiß nicht mehr, was das war, ich erinnere mich nur noch, dass ich einmal das gemacht habe, weil ich immer im Hinterkopf habe, ah, das wird dann nicht verteilt oder da muss man irgendwas 18 sein, das macht wahrscheinlich im Endeffekt überhaupt keinen Unterschied. Bei Spotify sieht man ja auch immer bei den Titeln explicit, wenn da was gesagt wird. Und deswegen muss ich vielleicht jetzt nochmal mehr explicit machen, aber auf der anderen Seite, wir sind doch alle so abgebrüht und abgestumpft, du kriegst doch wirklich an jeder Ecke da irgendwie ein dickes Paar Hupen ins Gesicht, irgendwie ist es doch in die Ecke. Wir sind doch schon als Gesellschaft so versext, so versaut, so verspritzt. Ich nehme das ganz anders wahr. Sind wir Dröge und Prüde? Dröge und Prüde und das wird uns, uns werden denkbar unerotische Sachen, als Erotik verkauft.
Und man muss ja nur mal ins Kino gehen, um zu merken, dass wir eine prüde, langweilige, unerotische Gesellschaft geworden sind. Ihr habt das Podcast-Urfe, mein Name ist Stefan Tietze, gegenüber von mir sitzt Florentin Will, freut mich sehr, dass ihr da seid. Danke, danke. Länger ins Intro. Das war richtig versaut, das war richtig gut, das war... Vielen Dank an Käthe, war ein bisschen peinlich, aber vielen Dank an Käthe, dass du uns hier mal wieder die Hose runtergezogen hast, dass wir hier mal wirklich klar auch kriegen, dass wir hier mal wirklich klar sehen, was wir hier eigentlich senden, denn wir hören uns die Folgen selber nicht mehr an, einfach aus Druck, weil man natürlich, wir gehen mit Druck auch in die Folge rein und natürlich bei eurer Kommentare. Und deswegen jetzt auch mal hier direkt, wir werden heute jetzt nicht irgendwie Zaubertricks machen oder witzige Anekdoten oder hier irgendwie von wegen Martin einblückeln. Du musst jetzt den ganzen Folgenplan umschmeißen. Nee, weil ich habe irgendwie auch keine Lust, weil der Druck wird zu hoch. Und deswegen irgendwie jedes, nein, aber jede Woche sich irgendwelche Sexunfälle auszudenken und sowas, das ist einfach auch anstrengend so. Ich will einfach auch mal frei von der Leber weg irgendwie und dieser ganze Druck, der aufgebaut wird, von wegen, ah, ich liebe ihre Fick-Tipps, ich liebe die Magie-Ecke, wo Zaubertricks gemacht werden, Wort-Jonglage, wo Stefan irgendwie ganz schwierige Worte ausspricht und so. Diese ganzen Rubriken, die uns seit vielen, vielen Jahren über Wasser halten, werden Hämorrhoiden. Hämorrhoide. Können Sie das Wort in einem Satz benutzen? Hämorrhoiden? Oh mein Gott, das sind die grössten Hämorrhoiden, die ich je gesehen habe, Herr Tietze. Worterkunft? Er kommt aus dem griechischen, Hämoron. Was heißt das? Der Sack. Hämorrhoiden, H-E-M-E-R. Leider nicht richtig. Was? Leider nicht richtig. Wie? Es ist H-E-H. H-E-M-E-H-E-H-E-O-H-M-H. Hämorrhoiden ist so weird, dass so Hämorrhoiden geschrieben wird.
Ja, Roids, so Roide, Roide.
Ja, Hämorrhoids.
Kannst du ja nicht schreiben. Es gibt viele Wörter, die ich wirklich mit der Kneifzange anfasse und wirklich nicht schreiben will.
Rhythmus der Klassiker wird immer umschrieben, mit Taktgefühl versuche ich immer zu umschreiben.
Und auch bei meinem Handy bin ich mittlerweile nicht mehr sicher, ob da die Autokorrektur hundertprozentig stimmt. Deswegen gehe ich viele Worte. Es werden bei mir auch Dinge falsch gemacht, habe ich das Gefühl. Die ich richtig schreibe, werden zu einem anderen Wort gemacht, was ich nicht meine. Das ist wirklich seltsam. Nee, es ist schwierig. Aber ich habe, wo wir gerade bei Sex und Männlichkeit und heißen schwitzenden Körpern waren, ich wurde extrem entmännlicht. Nicht nur ich, sondern es war eine ganze Episode der Entmännlichung, die stattgefunden hat und ich fand die sehr interessant und dachte mir... Eine Kaskade der Kastrierung. Genau, eine Kaskade der Kastrierungskasteiung. Das war sehr interessant, weil ich wurde losgeschickt zum Bäcker morgen, so sonntags zum Bäcker, der Bäckergang. Und ich sollte besorgen, und das war schon, ja, mit Ungläubigkeit habe ich dann diesen Auftrag entgegengenommen, ich sollte besorgen zwei Strongman-Brötchen. Und ich habe gesagt, ich werde das nicht kaufen. Ich werde keine zwei Strongman-Brötchen kaufen. Ah, du willst Mohnbrötchen? Ja? Du willst ein Mohnbrötchen und zwei Strongman-Brötchen? Nein, du kriegst drei Mohnbrötchen. Ja. Bin ich losgestiefelt, schon nervös und schwitzend und dachte mir, Strongman-Brötchen, was wenn die sagen, die gibt's nicht oder was soll das sein? Kannst du doch nicht tragen. Schau dir mal doch deine Ärmste. Genau, was wenn die sagen, nee, sie kriegen die nicht. Dann gehe ich rein und vor mir steht exakt ein Mann in meinem Alter, auch alleine, auch in diesem Sonntagsmorgens aus dem Bett geschubste Brötchen holen, Outfit. Er kommt dran, auch nervös, macht seine Bestellung und sagt, ach ja, und dann noch zwei Strongman-Brötchen. Und ich habe dann laut gelacht. Hast du ihn ausgelacht? Nein, meine Reaktion war natürlich, aha, er muss auch zwei Strongman-Brötchen kommen. Wir sind eine Schicksalsgemeinschaft und es war auch ein Lacher der Erleichterung. Der, aha, ich bin nicht der einzige Loser und ah, anscheinend gibt es die wirklich und ah, anscheinend werden die Männer in dieser Nachbarschaft losgeschickt, um Strongman-Brüten zu kaufen. Was ist das für eine Gesellschaft, sind die Männer verweichlicht, dass sie losgeschickt werden, um Strongman-Brüten zu kaufen? Naja, brauchen wir überhaupt Strongman-Brötchen? Muss ein Mann überhaupt strong sein, frage ich mich. Frag ich mich. Alles Fragen, die sich stellen.
Und das war eine grosse Lachung der Erleichterung, die mir da widerfahren ist.
Er hat durch beim Leidesgenossen das absolute Gegenteil ausgelöst.
Er dachte, ja, das war Strongman.
Vergessen Sie die.
Ciao, ciao, ciao.
Und da habe ich gesagt, nee, ich soll die auch kaufen.
Und da hat er auch laut gelacht, weil das auch, es war uns da so peinlich, dass wir dann so Strongman-Brötchen bestellen müssen.
Und das, weil das auch, es war uns da weiden so peinlich, dass wir dann so Strongman-Brötchen bestellen müssen. Und das, weil das ist ja hier, ich dachte, ich muss es dir erzählen, weil die Namen in Bäckereien begleitet uns ja schon ewig. Ja, absolut. Die Brötchen, Weltmeisterbrötchen, Knusperknacker, Knackerbrotzi, Knackerbrötchen, Pädobrötchenchen, was soll das eigentlich sein? Der Pädopumperdecke.
Was ist das eigentlich? Also da reicht's dann
irgendwann und das bleibt dann schon länger und du musst
es auch schon in deine Hose runterlassen. Ja, absolut.
Bei der Weckerei-Bestellung. Ich finde
bei Strongman-Brötchen,
was ist die Aussage dahinter?
Vor allem, haben wir nicht, also wie
krass ist denn eigentlich die Brötchen-Innovation,
dass jede Woche neue Brötchen
wiederkommen. Haben wir das nicht im Mittelalter
im Kloster einfach mal festgelegt, hier sind
Und jetzt ist es ein Wetter, der sich in den W, 10% Dinkel, was ist denn so, ja, nennt das so? Moment, 10% Dinkel ist ein Dinkel-Donkel-Christian, das habe ich doch letzte Woche schon gekauft, ihr nehmt das immer um. Dinkeldongel. Ja, hier zwei so Dinkeldongel. Dinkeldödel hatten wir doch. Habe ich doch letzte Woche schon peinlich hochrot gekauft. Dinkeldödel, Dinkeldildo. Bei mir ist es wirklich so, ich bin auch unsicher immer beim Bäcker. Und ich habe immer die gleiche Bestellung. Und jetzt habe ich beim Bäcker letztens gesehen, okay, ich sehe jetzt schon, es gibt keine Weltmassebrötchen, also zwei Laugenbrötchen mit Salz und die Person von mir sagt, ich hätte gern zwei Laugenbrötchen mit Salz. Und ich konnte dann nicht mehr das gleiche bestellen, weil das hätte sich so angefühlt, als würde ich der Person nachkaufen. Und ich habe dann was anderes bestellt. Und weil die Person dann auch so lange und Kaffee und hier und so und ich habe dann einfach gesagt, ich hätte gern zwei Mondbrötchen, weil das für mich sich zu nah angefühlt hat, dass die Person kauft er mir nach, rennt er mir schon seit Monaten nach und kauft versuchte er mich zu Hause nachzubauen Identitätsdienstall versuchte er sich meine Mannerismen anzueignen. Ja, wenn zwei Menschen sich exakt gleich ernähren, dann müssen die sich ja auf irgendeine Form annähern.
Also das ist ja dann Ähnlichkeiten so.
Das ist auch das Ding.
Und ich habe dir ja schon vor langer, langer Zeit erzählt von meinem Stammbäcker mit wie immer, mit zwei Weltmeisterbrötchen.
Weltmeisterbrötchen.
Sind wir nun mal Weltmeister oder nicht?
Ole!
Im Rugby. Im Rugby. Damen.by, im Damen-Rugby unter 18. Und habe ich dir erzählt, der Typ, der sogar über die normale Schlange hinweg, also ich bin in der Schlange an Platz drei und er reicht mir schon die Tüte nach hinten mit zwei Weltmeisterbrötchen. Und ich muss mit Karte zahlen. Hallo, das ist schrecklich. Und der letztens und mittlerweile, ich habe mich leider damit abgefunden, dass wenn der Typ Schicht hat, muss ich da leider einfach durch. Also gehe ich hin, Kopfhörer auf und er nur so, äh, hab ich gar nicht verstanden, er stand ein Stück weg von der Theke. Und du natürlich, ja, ja, danke. Und ich so, ja, ja, danke. Und dann sagte er, ah ja, okay, hier mit Karte.
Und es war ein anderer Betrag als sonst.
Ich dachte mir, krass, okay, wo wird das wohl nicht erhöht?
Okay, piep ab.
Und dann meint er so, ja, musst du dann noch selber gucken, was du dazu willst. Und deutet auf einen grossen Becher Kaffee.
Ein Kaffee.
So.
Jetzt, Moment.
Ich hätte ein ganz klares Bild von dem Herrn. Ein ganz klares Bild von ihm vor Augen. Weil ich dachte mir, okay, sowas machst du nur, wenn du bist on top of your game. Also du bist so gut, über dir gibt es keine besseren Bäckereifachverkäufer. Ja, ja. Du bist Pinnacle. Du hast auf eins. Wenn du diese Fähigkeit hast, über eine Schlange hinweg jemanden zu sehen, zu spotten und dann das Selbstbewusstsein genau zu wissen, was er immer nimmt, dann bist du am Start. Du bist auf dem Cover des Camps Magazine. Jetzt denk ich mir, vollidiot. Weil das, wenn ihm dann sowas passiert, mit Anlauf, also unbedrängt, die Bestung nicht abzuwarten, eh schon dir aufzudiktieren, weil Leute wie dir können ja nicht sagen, ich will was ganz anderes heute. Jesus, und dann hast du den Kaffee genommen. Dann stand da ein Kaffee und ich dachte mir, ja und zwei Weltmeisterbrötchen, er so, ah ja, okay, krieg noch zwei Weltmeisterbrötchen, ich zahle nochmal und ich nehme den Kaffee und gehe. Aber der Typ... Und der Kaffee war teurer als zwei Weltmeisterbrötchen? Ja, der Kaffee war richtig teuer. Das war so ein grosser Cappuccino. Ich weiss auch nicht wo. Das war ein grosser Frappuccino mit Karamellcreme. Auch nicht wo in dieser Diskussion eher einen grossen Cappuccino. Das Geile ein bisschen daran ist, du bist jetzt frei. Ich bin auf eine Art frei, weil das hat mich echt gewundert, weil der Typ hat wirklich dutzende Male, ah wie immer, ah wie immer, wortlos, immer zwei, meistens mal Brötchen, ich war zufrieden, war heute Schenk. Was für ein Schakaufs-Genie. Vielleicht, ja. Schmeisst so neue Sachen rein. Jaja, und einfach auch vor allem, ich habe Kopfhörer getragen, und zack, und dann
stellte ich mir einen Kaffee hin.
Dann kriegst du so eine Riesentüche,
diese Vorbestellung, so Berliner,
so 500 Berliner mit. Geil.
Und dann stehst du da und dachte mir,
das kann doch nicht wahr sein.
Der ganze Leidensweg, den ich
durchlitten habe, hat mir
zumindest immer gegeben,
dass ich verlässlich zwei Weltmeisterbrüche habe. Und jetzt kriege ich hier so einen riesen Cappuccino, habe dann den Cappuccino mitgenommen, keine Ahnung, was ich dann machen soll, habe die dann der Kollegin geschickt, die dann um 17 Uhr noch einen Cappuccino getrunken hat und mir danach gesagt hat, sie konnte die ganze Nacht nicht schlafen. Also der Kollateralschaden, der einfach daran hing, dass man so, äh zu viel Verantwortung. Nach nicht geschlafen, Prüfung nicht danach, am nächsten Tag Fahrtprüfung nicht bestanden. Nicht bestanden, Job nicht bekommen, ich wollte eigentlich die Wohnung, Besichtigungstermin, hab da auf dem Boden gekotzt, hab die Wohnung nicht bekommen, mein Leben ist ruiniert wegen Job. Viel zu viel Verantwortung auf diesem kurzen Moment. Ich meine, du hättest an 15 Punkten diese Interaktion sagen können, nee, ich hab keinen Kaffee bestellt. Nee, auf keinen Fall. Aber, ne, ja. Vor allem, ich weiss ja, der muss den Kaffee dann wegschütten und so, das will er nicht. Ich will es mir doch nicht mit der einen Person. Sie wollen ihn nicht. Ah, okay. Na, dann schütte ich ihn mir ins Gesicht. Ja, das will ich nicht, dass der dann wegen mir leidet. Deswegen, mit Leuten, mit denen du jeden Tag zu tun hast, musst du es dir gutstellen. Immer gutstellen, deswegen bin ich jetzt echt gespannt, weil das war jetzt die letzte Interaktion, wie jetzt die nächste Interaktion aussieht. Also ist es die nächste Evolutionsstufe? Muss ich jetzt genau hinhören, was er sagt? Ach, Cappuccino? Aber ganz ehrlich, es ist ja, habe ich bei dem fantastischen Podcast, haben wir schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, die neun Zwanziger gelernt habe, dass diese Interaktionen, diese kleinen Interaktionen im Leben, das sind die Aktionen, die dich länger leben lassen, das sind die Interaktionen, die sich auf Lebensqualität auswirken. Es sind nicht die langfristigen Beziehungen, fuck them, scheissegal.
Nee, es geht wirklich tatsächlich um die kleinen Interaktionen mit Nachbarn, beim Bäcker. die langfristigen Beziehungen, fuck them. Ist scheißegal.
Es geht wirklich tatsächlich um die kleinen Interaktionen mit Nachbarn,
beim Bäcker, bei der Kasse
und sowas. Das sind die Aktionen, die
wichtig sind. Deswegen habe ich gedacht,
und diese Aktionen,
ich verstehe das schon, weil
klar, ich dreaded davor, ich habe
Angst, aber wenn die
gut und smooth liefen und man wurde irgendwie nett begrüsst. Also zum Beispiel, ich lebe in einer Nachbarschaft, wo man dann auch schon den Kioskmann kennt, wo man die Pakete abholt und so weiter. Und die Interaktionen sind immer super nett und irgendwie auf eine Art schön distanziert. Das ist eben nicht so, ah, jetzt verwelte man das Messerbruchchen, bitte. Und auch nicht so ein, das macht er super, der gibt einem nicht das Gefühl, dass er trackt, wie viele Pakete du bekommst. Ja, ja, und von wem. Genau. Und wie schwer. Ja, genau. Und welches tropft und welches nicht. Genau, und welches spricht. Und welches spricht. Und warum ist das so eine Form, warum hat sich die Form eines Golfschlägers. Ja. Diese ganzen Sachen werden nicht thematisiert, es ist ein distanziertes Hey, und dann wird kurz über irgendwas gelabert. Aber das ist super, der macht richtig gut. Und diese Aktionen, wenn die gut laufen und die sind wie nett, dann gehe ich mit einem Lachen raus aus dem Laden. Denke mir so, schön, man fühlt sich willkommen. Wenn dann auch die Sonne scheint, alle sind gut drauf, Leute gehen mit dem Lachen durch die Nachbarschaft. Das ist vielleicht der Höhepunkt deiner Woche. Exakt. Also das ist das Leben, das wir führen. Super, das ist das Leben, das wir führen, da sind wir gelandet, dankeschön.
So, und deswegen verstehe ich das voll und ich glaube, wir sind da,
bei uns könnte es auch genau in eine andere Richtung gehen,
weil wir auch Angst haben vor diesen Interaktionen,
weil wir zu sehr gefallen
wollen, zu wenig den Betriebsablauf stören wollen,
wir sind dann im Zweifel,
die Leute, die
ja, nicht mit den Leuten reden oder
distanziert kühl wirken, weil wir nicht den Betriebsablauf stellen wollen und dann uns da hinstellen wollen, haben das Geld passend oder die Karte bereits schauen, gezückt, sagen, vier normale Brötchen, danke und dann gehen wir zur Seite, aber so entsteht vielleicht nicht das, was unsere Lebenskönlichkeit nachhaltig verbessert. Ich denke jetzt tatsächlich über einen neuen Podcast nach, einen Interview-Podcast, Name, die Service-Ecke.
Und zwar, ich rede mit Servicepersonal und wirklich alles auf den Tisch.
Wie soll man mit euch reden? Wie soll man mit euch umgehen? Was mögt ihr? Trinkgeld, ja, nein. Was mögt ihr nicht? Weil ich hatte jetzt letztens die Situation, und das macht mich fertig so, ich bestelle ungefähr einmal in der Woche irgendwas und ich hatte immer mein Kleingeld parat, immer zwei Euro Stück Trinkgeld hatten wir schon hundertmal erzählt. Jetzt habe ich mein Kleingeld einmal entsorgt und mein Leben komplett 180 gedreht. Ich habe kein Kleingeld mehr, nichts. Was dazu führt, dass ich kein Trinkgeld mehr an der Tür geben kann, deswegen gebe ich Trinkgeld digital. Ja, unser Journalismus-Rottweiler Thais hetzt immer noch dieser Fährte nach, dass dieses Online-Trinkgeld gar nicht tot. Sternchen, vielleicht auch nicht, vielleicht ist es schon lange gestorben. Genau, wir haben ja dann Whistleblower bekommen, dass dieses Online-Trinkgeld gar nicht bei den Booten ankommt, das ist natürlich furchtbar. Das stimmt nicht, doch bei Dominus, nur bei Dominus. Bei Dominus, genau, stimmt Dominus, aber gut, wenn einer das so macht, kann natürlich das alles so. Ja, vor allem haben wir explizit das Gegenteil gehört. Okay, gut, so, jetzt ist es weder Dominus noch Lieferando, deswegen ist es offen. Wollt. Und deswegen sage ich immer, ich habe das Trinkgeld ja schon gegeben, sage ich immer an der Tür, weil ich auch nicht weiß, ob die schon davor wissen. Und immer ist es ein trauriger Moment und immer guckt er traurig, weil ich habe mal gehört, dass erst wenn du die Lieferung abschließt, der Bote hat ja auch so eine App, erst wenn du die abschließt, habe ich gegeben,
erst dann siehst du Trinkgeld oder nicht.
Und deswegen sage ich nichts dann noch, dass die Person nicht sauer auf mich ist. Wir haben bei Lieferando
mal gehört,
ja, wir kriegen das Trinkgeld tatsächlich zu 100%
und wir erfahren
es aber erst nach der Transaktion.
Genau. Und ich behaupte
auch, ich kann anhand der Reaktion
der Leute, wenn ich die Tür zumache und sage, Dankeschön, ciao, und die sagen, guten Appetit, kann ich erkennen, ob die das vorher gewiss mitbekommen haben oder nicht, weil ich glaube, die leben tatsächlich vom Trinkgeld, und wenn man denen das nicht gibt, ist es einfach scheiße, und dann sind die da hingefallen und dann ist es einfach kacke, und zweifelig Regen oder Kälte, whatever. Und bei Lieferando habe ich es gemerkt, die sind schlecht drauf, wenn man das nicht gibt, und gucken sie nachher drauf und denken, ja okay, well, he's fine. Genau. Deswegen sage ich das jetzt immer dazu. Das finde ich schrecklich. Und es ist furchtbar, weil du musst es immer so betonen. Du gibst dir die Blöße, weil du betonst, ich möchte gerade nicht schlecht wegkommen. Ich habe es dir gegeben, aber ich will auch deine unmittelbar es ist fast Fishing for Thank Yous. Ja, aber ich habe auch das Gefühl, die mögen das weniger, weil die gucken dann immer nicht so happy, als wenn du denen einfach zwei Euro gibst oder so. Keine Ahnung, ob das auch geteilt wird oder so. Deswegen meine Idee, der Podcast, die Service-Ecke. Lass uns solche Sachen mal klären. Das Problem ist, die Leute dürfen natürlich nicht, die müssen anonym sein, damit sie nicht ihren Job verlieren, weil es kann ja sein, aber ich will das alles auf den Tisch. Weil manchmal gibt es so Momente der Ehrlichkeit zwischen Kunde und Dienstleister. Ja, wenn die Stimmung gut ist und super gut, ja, ja, ja. Oder ich habe zum Beispiel auch mal häufiger bei einem Laden über Lieferando, also ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt verboten ist, aber ich habe über Lieferando bestellt und irgendwann war in dem Essen so ein kleiner Zettel drin. Ja, habe ich auch schon. Und da stand drin, hey, danke, dass wir uns bestellen, aber bestellt doch bitte auf unserer eigenen Website, damit wir nicht ein Lieferando Gebühren abführen müssen. Vielleicht ist das illegal, dass die das machen, vielleicht ist es ausgeschlossen, irgendwann, keine Ahnung. Aber solche Sachen gerne einfach mal offen klären. Und deswegen würde ich gerne sitzen hier, mir gegenüber, halt weniger mit dir, dass ich halt weniger mit dir mache, vielleicht zweiwöchig oder so, und dafür halt dann auch einmal oder mehrmals pro Woche mache ich die Service, wo ich alleine dann hier mit einem Pizzaboten sitze und einfach mal sage, wir müssen das abgeben, weil du musst es ja verzerren alles, damit es nicht zurückgeführt werden kann. Wir kriegen gar nichts. Wir kriegen absolut gar nichts. Wir werden geschlagen, wir werden es in Druck gezogen. Wir kriegen nichts. Bis zur Unverständlichkeit verzerrt. Wir kriegen gar nichts. Nichts. Nichts. Also, und es bin offensichtlich immer ich. Genau, und er so, das Interview wurde nachgesprochen von Stefan Tietze. Könnten wir natürlich auch machen, dass wir es dann nochmal nach und du einfach so von so einem Blatt abliest. Ich merke schon, du willst mich da irgendwie raus rationalisieren. Nee, du kannst Social Media machen, dachte ich. Ja. Das ist ja, nee, nee, du kriegst ja einen Platz. Aber kriege ich dann Stefans Wissenschaftsecke, wo ich dann irgendwie biweekly meine WissenschaftlerInnen. Du kannst für mich aus die Medizinecke haben. Dann so, wie verhalte ich mich beim Urologen, wie verhalte ich mich beim Frauenarzt und sowas. Einfach so, wie ist das hier? Medizin. Warum machst du mich klein? Medizin. Du bist Service. Medizin ist nicht so klein. Aber das würde ich mir gerne wünschen, mehr Offenheit. Vorschlag zu Güte, Vorschlag, wir machen daraus eine Rubrik im Podcast-UFO. ähm, wir, schreibt uns doch gerne mal, wenn ihr da seid,
seid ihr Kellner im Restaurant, Kellnerin,
oder arbeitet ihr bei Lieferando, seid Fahrerin, Fahrer? Das ist doch geil. Und wir telefonieren mit euch. Vielleicht, wie wir es immer hatten, mit Philipp Hauptmann. Müssen wir das abklären davor, ob die echt sind. Ja, klar. Und dann aber wirklich auch so Pet-Peeves. Ich hasse es, wenn Kunden das und das machen bei der Bäckerei, ich hasse das, wenn die so lange nach dem Kleingeld suchen, ich hasse das, wenn die nicht grüßen, irgendwie sowas so. Haut mal raus, was stört euch wirklich? Und was ist euch auch egal? Es kann ja sein, mir ist scheißegal, ob der mich grüsst oder nicht, so völlig egal, das kann ja auch sein, dass man denkt, irgendwas sei total wichtig, ist es aber nicht. Was ich immer zum Beispiel von einem Kellner nicht machmachen und nicht auf alle projizieren oder so, aber was ich immer gehört habe, ist, dass, weil es gilt ja die 10%-Regel bei Trinkgeld und ich habe immer allen gesagt, ey, wenn mir ganz viele Leute am Tisch sind, 10% trotzdem. Nicht dann irgendwie aufrunden auf die nächsten, also den Fünfer aufrunden oder so, sondern gibt einfach fucking 10%, auch wenn die Rechnung quasi nicht 500 Euro sind, weil wir viele Leute sind.
Ach so, du hast animiert mehr zu geben.
Immer, genau, immer 10% und nicht einfach nur aufzurunden. Wenn die Rechnung, sagen wir mal jetzt, der Einfachheit halber, 495 Euro ist, gibt 50 Euro Trinkgeld und nicht 5 Euro. Und alle immer so, ja wow, das ist aber sehr viel Geld. Meine Mom musste mal für ihren damaligen Chef so ein Essen organisieren und da hat sie dann auch auf 10% aufgerunden und hat nachher Anschluss bekommen, weil das so viel Geld war. Ja, ja. Meiner Meinung nach hat sie es richtig gemacht. Dann hat mir aber jetzt ein Kellner gesagt, ähm, nee, bei solchen Summen, who cares, wirklich, einfach nur, gibt es nicht so viel zu wenig, aber dann macht ein Zehner oder so, es muss aber nicht mehr 10% sein. Da dachte ich mir, spannend. Da habe ich gedacht, das ist so ein krass. Warum solltet ihr das sagen? Also es will ja nicht so viel Geld, wie es geht. Ich glaube, wenn du in solchen Restaurants bist, wo so eine Summe eine Rolle spielt, keine Ahnung, ob es dann besser bezahlt ist oder man muss es eh teilen oder so, keine Ahnung. Aber deswegen meine ich, wahrscheinlich gilt es auch jetzt nicht für alle Restaurants und die meisten freuen sich trotzdem über Geld und es ist immer schöner, einem Servicepersonal mehr zu geben als zu wenig. Ich glaube nur, dass meine Angst, ich werde knallrot, wenn jemand zu wenig Trinkgeld gibt. Ich finde das super unangenehm. Ich glaube, in einem krassen Betriebsablauf ist das, sei einfach kein Schnipser oder so, ist das viel grössere Übel für einen oder jemand, der ständig Gerichte zurückgibt oder sagt, es ist mir ein bisschen zu wenig medium rare, whatever. Das ist viel nerviger als derjenige, der zwei Euro zu wenig Fricke gibt. Oder zu lange bleiben oder so, dass man nicht abschliesslich... Lieb ich, die Servicetheke. Florentins Servicetheke, dass wir das mal einführen und dann wirklich alles offen, weil wir brauchen auch Leute, die ehrlich sind. Ich habe das Gefühl, du willst mich also rausrationalis ist. Ich will aber, dass ihr ehrlich seid. Ich will, dass ihr ehrlich seid. Weil zum Beispiel, manchmal ist es ja so, du gehst zum Friseur und hast irgendwie zum Beispiel, ich hatte das eine Zeit lang so am Ohr, so nicht so Ausschlag, aber so krustig irgendwie einfach so am Ohr. So, man hat ja manchmal irgendeinen Scheiss einfach am Körper. Und ich dachte mir so. Ja, niemand sonst hat das. Ja, ja, ja. Und beim Friseur musst du ja auch so am Ohr. Und ich dachte mir, ist das super eklig für den Friseur, wenn der Kunde irgendwie so grint oder krustig oder irgendwie so Ausschlag hat? Oder sehen die das gar nicht? Sind die so auf Haar oder haben die schon alles gesehen wie so ein Arzt, der sagt, mir ist alles egal? Was könnte denn Stefans einziger Service-Ecke? Der Friseur ist ja nicht Arzt. Da würde ich mir auch wirklich super Ehrlichkeit wünschen, dass er sagt, wenn ihr so einen Ausschlagscheiß habt, geht nicht zum Friseur, ihr habt keinen Bock auf sowas. Wir brauchen knallharte, ehrliche Leute, nicht, ja, Hauptsache der Kunde ist zufrieden. So was brauchen wir gar nicht. Wir brauchen wirklich, wenn ihr von der Arbeit nach Hause kommt und euer Freund oder eure Freundin sitzt auf der Couch und sagt, wie war der Tag und ihr fuckt euch ab, was die Kunden Farschlöcher sind. Das wollen wir, den Juice. Das, genau dieses Gespräch, genau dieses Gespräch wollen wir haben. Und ihr seid anonym, bis der Server gehackt wird oder das Podcast-Uvo pleite geht und wir alles verkaufen müssen mit den ganzen Mails und Daten. Mit unserem DNA-Strengen. Das kann dann natürlich passieren, aber bis dah immer mit Ehrlichkeit. Ich war neulich in einer Situation, was sehr spannend war. In meinem Haus hat noch jemand zur gleichen Zeit etwas bestellt. Der Lieferandofahrer kam dann hin und ich hab dann, es hat bei mir geklingelt, ich hab gesagt, einfach hochkommen und dann hat der Nachbar unten, ganz unten gesehen, ah, Lieferando ist da, macht die Tür unten auf und sagt, ah, vielen Dank, nehmt ihm das Essen ab, mein Essen, gibt ihm Trinkgeld und sagt, ciao. Und ich rufe hinunter zum Livferantwofer und sag, sorry, mein Essen? Und er sagt, ja, habe ich euch doch gegeben. Und er hat gesagt, nee, das ist mein Essen. In dem Moment geht der Nachbar unten raus und sagt, ah, ich habe gar nicht bei Subway bestellt. Ich sag, nee, ich habe bei Subway bestellt. So, und dann bin ich runtergelaufen, um mir mein Essen zu holen. Und dieser super unangenehme Moment ist dann entstanden, wo der Nachbar unten gesagt hat, oh, aber jetzt habe ich dir ja Trinkgeld gegeben. Und ich bin fast einfach, ich bin so zerschmolzen. Wie gesagt, eben hoch. Aber voll einfach das zurück, ey. Das ist aber, ja, ja, nee, komm, du kannst... Natürlich nicht, natürlich nicht, also alle, jede Faser meines Körpers schreit, der Hund. Als ob es ein Problem wäre, dass die Leute zu viel Trinken entgegen. Und dann wurde es doch viel schlimmer, dann wurde aus dem, ich hatte ja gerade Trinken gegeben für Essen, was ich dir nicht gebe und ich muss dir ja auch noch Trinken geben, wurde dann aus einem super so Rubenöstl und gönnerisches, so gönnerhaftes
Nee, komm.
Nee, komm, behalt.
Und er so, ja, danke.
Oder du so,
ja gut, aber da muss ich jetzt kein Trinkgeld mehr geben.
Und ich habe online gegeben, nämlich
online gegeben, nimm's ihm
ab, das Hessen und geh hoch.
Und der Nachbar dachte,
wow, ich gebe hier allen Leuten Trinkgeld und Stefan, mein Nachbar, who the fuck is this guy? Dieses Online-Trinkgeld ist der Fluch der Neuzeit. Es entstehen, das ist wirklich Curb, wo du hundert Folgen Curb mannst. Man braucht auf dem Shirt, muss stehen, ich gebe Online-Trinkgeld. Genau, Merch? Merch. Florentins Merch-Ecke? Das Florentin.shop ist vielleicht noch, vielleicht können wir da was einrichten. Vielleicht können wir da was einrichten. Du kriegst ein wenig Applaus, brauchst du mehr Applaus, du hast dich immer umarmen, du bist irgendwie... Nee, ich bin nur einfach von, ich finde einfach, du bist nicht mehr, also du... Ich glaube, es geht gar nicht um mich, sondern einfach, dass du... Du, ich soll einfach, also es geht... Du hast nicht das Gefühl, du bist grösser Schein. Genau, ich will eigentlich, dass du kleiner wirst. Ich will dich runterskalieren wie im Photoshop, dass du so ein bisschen runter bist. Ich bin zu gross, Körpergrösse ist ein Körpergrossproblem. Aber ich hatte auch jetzt eine Interaktion an der Tür mit irgendwie Naturschutzverein. Bunddeutscher Mädchen. Bunddeutscher Schützer. Und sehr krass, die kam dann rum und meinte so, ja, wir machen ganz viele Projekte hier, Wildkatzen und Glimitrei-Streifen und die Orchideen und alles und ich so, ah, cool, super, ist ja eine tolle Sache, wer könnte da was dagegen haben?
und dann so, ja und wir machen, wenn du dann dich bei uns anmeldest, dann haben wir auch mehr politischen Einfluss und so und dann so, hier kannst du dich immer eintragen und es kostet nichts und ich so, ja okay, ich schau mir das mal an und die wirklich, ja, meistens wenn die Leute das sagen, dann machen sie es am Ende doch nicht, also du kannst dich ja jetzt schon mal eintragen. Holy shit, das mache ich schon nicht, du bist entdacht. Und das ist so wirklich ein bisschen gekippt bei mir, wenn ich so, ja, trag dich schon mal ein, es kostet nichts und dann hat sie auch wirklich in den AGB grossgezogen, kein Beitrag fällig und so und hat wirklich jedes Argument, das sie schon hunderte Male gehört hat, alles vorweggenommen, sodass sie mich wirklich in eine Ecke gedrängt hat und dann meinte sie, kannst du mir mal kurz sagen, warum du dich jetzt nicht direkt anmelden kannst, vielleicht können wir dann auch die, vielleicht kann ich dir da weiterhelfen und ich dann so, ich will es einfach nicht, ich will es mir erstmal durchlesen und dann hat sie gefragt, hast du denn vielleicht schlechte Erfahrungen mal gemacht mit so einer Anmeldung und ich und dann habe ich gesagt, aber das ist eine falsche Frage, das ist dieses Problem, dieses wenn man Weltkriegsflieger, wenn die zurückkommen und du guckst die Einschusslöcher, wo werden die am meisten getroffen und zurückkommen und man würde ja intuitiv diese Stellen besonders schützen. Nee, du musst gucken, wo wurden die nicht getroffen, weil die Flieger, die nicht zurückkamen, die wurden ja abgeschossen, das sind ja die Liesel-Stellen. Und genau so ist es, wenn man dich fragt, was hast du eine negative Erfahrung gemacht und du sagst, nein, ist es ja eine gute Sache, weil du diesen Scheiß nicht unterschreibst. Weil du so bist, wie du bist, machst du keine negativen Erfahrungen. Das ist eigentlich die Frage falsch gestellt. Und sowas musstest du ihr dann sagen. Ja, ich war nicht schnell genug, ich war nicht schnell genug, ich habe das als meinen einzigen Rettungsweg gesehen und habe gesagt, ja, ich habe schon mal schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht. Und ich habe innerlich gesagt, bitte, bitte, bitte stell keine Nachfrage, ich hätte nichts. Und die so, ah, okay, ja gut, das verstehe ich. Na, dann überlegst du dir mal, ich gebe dir mal einen Flyer. Und ich dachte mir so, das war so penetrant und die war so gut in ihrem Job, weil ihr Job ist ja auch einfach, die fucking Unterschriften zu kriegen, Zahl, klar ist die Aktivistin und idealistisch und so, aber am Ende hilft es ja nichts, wenn alle ihre Arbeit toll finden, aber niemand einfach dieses fucking Formular ausfüllt. Gäbe es denn irgendeinen Weg? Einfach pressen, pressen, pressen. Das Geile ist, sie ist Brute Force. Sie ist Frau Brute Force. Ja. Weil sie mit geballtem Wissen diesen Fragebäum durchgespielt hat, dutzende Male. Sie weist auf jedes Argument, was irgendwo in diesem Wahrscheinlichkeitsbaum kommt, hat sie eine geile Antwort. Ausser auf deine Lüge. Ja, ich habe schon mal eine schlechte Erfahrung. Weil das ist ja auch, hast du schon mal eine schlechte Erfahrung gemacht und sie hat geile Antwort wahrscheinlich auf nein, genau, dann machst du halt, wovor hast du dann Angst, aber sie hat keine gute Antwort auf die offensichtliche Lüge ja, dann musst du ja einfach sagen, okay, hier ist mein Flyer, überleg's dir, aber gäbe es denn mal anders gefragt, eine Wahrscheinlichkeitsbaumrute, wo du das gemacht hättestest. Ich weiß, ich kann auch nicht sagen, warum ich es nicht gemacht habe. Es ist nur, man will sich einfach nicht committen auf irgendwas. Die haben es so schwer. Aber du sitzt ja da nicht in einem Verein jede Woche. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Aber diese Situation Klemmbrett-Formular, glaube ich, jeder ist da so drauf getrimmt mit, ich habe da mal was unterschrieben und dann wurde jeden Monat abgebucht und ich habe mich da in so eine Mitleidsnummer reinziehen lassen, wie
ich habe mal so Krankenwagen
für Säuglinge, habe ich mal unterschrieben.
Es gibt Krankenwagen für Menschen,
für Erwachsene en masse, aber
es gibt keine Krankenwagen für Säuglinge,
die ganz besonders klein sind.
Ja, smart.
Du kriegst ja so Säugling nicht in normalen
Krankenwagen rein.
Nein, die fliegen da rum.
Und dann dachte ich mir, die flügelst du Flummi.
Und dann geht es denen oft noch schlechter.
Manchmal aber ganz selten noch besser, tatsächlich.
Aber allermeistens noch schlechter.
Und da habe ich unterschrieben und auch ewig abgebucht,
weil die mich halt rein in so eine Mitleidsnummer reingezogen haben.
Wer ist denn dagegen, dass Säuglinge, die haben ja nichts falsch gemacht.
Die meisten, die allermeisten haben nichts falsch gemacht.
Das ist natürlich auch ein schwieriges Formular. Es ist super, weil ich denke mir so, hä, zahlt das nicht irgendwie der Staat oder so? Wer zahlt denn sonst für Krankenwägen? Ist das nicht so Versicherung? Ich weiß so wenig über diese Welt, dass ich gar nicht Wohltätigkeit als solches überhaupt verstehen kann. Weil ich mir denke, hä, gibt's da nicht Institutionen dafür? Keine Ahnung. Das Prinzip, von Tür zu Tür zu gehen, um Unterschriften zu brauchen, das ist bei mir schon die Red Flag. Also warum läuft's bei euch PR-technisch so schlecht? Also was ist falsch an eurer Kommunikation, dass das der Weg ist? Und ich weiß, es ist nicht richtig, dieser Gedanke. Aber das kommt leider bei mir an. Weil ich denke, wenn der Zweck so gut und wichtig ist, dann kriegt ihr den doch besser kommuniziert inzwischen online. Also wenn ihr so viel geilen Scheiss macht und so geilen aktivistischen Kram für die Tiere in eurer Umgebung macht, das ist doch etwas, was man sehr, sehr gut, wo man sehr, sehr gut Geld für bekommen kann, wenn man das gut kommuniziert. Das denke ich halt, ich glaube, die haben ein Problem, dass die Zustimmung sich nicht übersetzt in Aktionen. Alle sagen, oh, das ist ja super, das ist ja toll mit den Tieren, toll, tschüss, Tür zu, vergessen, schön, Fernseher an, nie wieder dran gedacht und die haben davon gar nichts. Tidoku, Tidoku an, wo man denkt, oh, der geht so schlecht, da sollte man aber was machen. Genau, so und dann, die müssen halt irgendwas kriegen. Ich habe mich mittlerweile übrigens über das Online-Formular angemeldet, kostenlos, habe noch keinen Beitrag gezahlt, will jetzt keine Lorbeeren ernten, Aber ich bin drin, weil ich hatte nochmal drüber nachgedacht und dachte mir, ja, die hat schon auch einen scheiss Job und kriegt wahrscheinlich den ganzen Tag Zustimmung und Lächeln und toll, was die für Arbeit machen. Und am Ende des Tages hat sie null Unterschriften und nichts. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, ist schon blöd. Aber das war so penetrant einfach, wirklich so eindringlinghaft. Und diese Unterschrift ist so ein, ich will das nicht unterschreiben. Ja, auch ein Problem ist natürlich diese Penetranz, sorgt natürlich dafür, dass man denkt, okay, warum brauchst du das so dringend, weil sonst keiner unterschreibt, unterschreiben zu wenige, warum unterschreiben das zu wenige? Das ist dann die Frage, diese, also manche jetzt so Strassenmusiker zum Beispiel, machen sich ja so ein bisschen Geld vorher in den Hut, damit es zu viel haben. Weil sie zu viel haben. Nicht wissen, wohin damit. Nee, weil sie sich sozusagen, das können sie dann absetzen. Naja. Ausgaben. Nein, aber dann sieht es aus, okay, da geben Leute was, dann gibt man wahrscheinlich eher immer was. Und was andere Menschen machen mit der, ja, das kennt man ja psychologisch, bin ich der Erste. Und deswegen frage ich mich, haben sie wohl vorher schon mal so, genau diese Penetranz sagt dann auch, fuck, wir haben keiner. Stimmt, wahrscheinlich wenn du so ein Formular hast mit Unterschriften, wenn das schon halb voll ist, kann man wahrscheinlich statistisch machen. Zwei Seiten erstmal voll schreiben. Okay, du musst blättern und dann hin. Und du magst ja auch nicht alle Tiere gleich viel. Ich weiss, du hast ein Problem mit Luchsen. Naturschutz ist ja ein Konzept, wo ich mir denke, Natur an sich ist nicht gut. Natur ist irgendwelche Froschplagen, Heuschrecken, Pilze, irgendwelche giftigen Schlangen. Das ist alles Natur, das ist aber alles Crab, das will ich nicht. Blaualgen, du bist ein Froschplagen. Richtig, ich will die süssen Kätzchen, ich will Kühe die Milch geben, ich will vielleicht ab und zu malen Tiger oder so, aber den ganzen Crab-Rest mit irgendwelchen Stinktieren oder Tollwut-Füchsen will ich nicht. Und dann auch so Krötenwanderungen, Kröten sind mir suspekt, ich will wirklich für jedes Tier, deswegen, ich habe ja einmal für Luchse gespäht und es bereut, Das hätte ich glaube ich, ich hätte tatsächlich, ich habe im Nachhinein überlegt, was hätte ich gesagt, wenn sie gefragt hätte, was ist ihre schlechte Erfahrung mit Naturschutz, was eine tolle Frage ist, die jeder für sich auch mal gerne beantworten kann, hätte ich wahrscheinlich sowas gesagt wie, ich habe mal für Füchse gespendet und dann hat mich beim Joggen Fuchs gebissen. Und seitdem möchte ich da einfach, weil du weißt ja nicht, wen du am Ende unterstützt. Ich weiß nicht, ob der spezifische Fuchs jetzt Unterstützung bekommen hat, um mich zu beißen, hätte der mich auch gebissen, weiss man, kann man immer nicht sagen, kann man immer nicht sagen. Aber ganz, ganz null Prozent sind es halt nie. Wenn sie mir hier an Ordnungsstelle an meiner Haustür versprechen können, dass Füchse nicht unterstützt werden auch. Und dann muss sie den Vertrag so anpassen. Ihrere 2,50 Euro im Jahr werden nicht an Füchse überliefert. So wie beim Organspendeausweis, wo du sagst, ich helfe allen Tieren und dann hinten drauf, ausser, naja, naja, naja, Luchs, Fuchs, Dachs, weg damit. Alles mit X. Alles mit X. Kein Weg. Warum mit X? Kein Weg. Gibt ja auch nicht nur gute Tiere. Aber wo ich immer offen bin und was ich diese Woche auch gemacht habe und was immer schön ist, und da bin ich offen, da zücke ich auch mein Portemonnaie sofort, ist dein Eis-Subway. Eis-Tee bei Subway. Und da gibt es jetzt die neue Sorte, Blaubeeren. Nein, ich war schön bei mir unterwegs, bin in den Spaziergang und dann habe ich einen Anblick gesehen, den ich immer gerne sehe, nämlich Kinder, die einen Laden haben. Kinder-Laden. Boah, ich bin kein Fan von Kinderläden. Ich liebe Kinderläden. Kinderläden, wirklich mit alten Spielsachen, Kinder und Läden, no go. Kinder und Läden, ich liebe Kinderläden. Kinderläden, wirklich mit alten Spielsachen, selbstgemalt Sachen. Kinder und Läden, nein, das ist Kreuz, das ist Emoji-Kreuz. Kann ich verstehen, aber ich liebe es, weil ich habe das als Kind auch gemacht und ich habe mir viel Geld verdient. Wir haben damals uns schön bei Aldine Park und Gummibärchen gekauft und haben die an der Strasse für fünf Cent pro Gummibärchen, wahrscheinlich Pfennig Fünf Pfennig pro Gummibärchen verkauft. Wir haben die alle ausgepackt, alle einzeln angefingert. Das ist es nämlich. Popelnde Popelkits. Rückblickend haben die sich am Arsch kratzen und dann die Gummibärchen auspacken. Die Hälfte davon ist runtergefallen, weil der Tisch falsch aufgebaut wurde, liegt im Dreck und dann so, ja, wo können wir noch verkaufen? Oh, oh, meia! Das ist alles so richtig. Ich habe mir ricklingend auch gedacht, jeder, weil wir haben uns da an so einem Wanderweg aufgestellt, wo man so sehen konnte, man hinwandern bei uns in der Siedlung und da war viel los, war ein schöner sonniger Tag. Anhand, wie du Natur beschreibst, dass du aus einem schöneren Bundesland kommst. Ja, na klar. Oder da könnte man so zu Seen laufen.en laufen. Bei uns konnte man zu einer Zeche laufen, da hinten ist so ein Museum drin. Zur Kohlegrube konnte man laufen, wollte aber Einschutzgefährdung. Rückblickend dachte ich mir, jeder, der hier von uns Gummibärchen gekauft hat, hat die zwei Meter danach weggeschmissen. Hat die entweder weggeworfen und oder A Aber du machst gut Geld, ne? Also wie viele Gummibärchen sind uns in einer Gummipackung? Mal fünf Fanning holst du locker wieder rein, Startkapital hast du von deinen Eltern geholt und dann hast du gut Geld gemacht. Und deswegen bin ich da immer... Ja, das ist super viel Geld. Und deswegen bin ich immer guter Dinge. Ich bin gelaufen mit meinen Kopfhörern und hat mich so ein Mädchen angesprochen. Ja, Entschuld wir machen einen Laden, wollen Sie mal gucken? Und ich, yes, sofort. Laden und dann steht an der Tür, steht diese Naturschutzfrau und sagt, was, hierfür gibst du jetzt Geld aus, die haben die Gummibärchen einfach neu verbracht? Ich habe noch nie eine schlechte Erfahrung mit einem Kinderladen gemacht und die hat ein geiles Sortiment. Und dann, vor allem mein Problem war, die waren teilweise sehr gute Verkäuferin, teilweise sehr schlechte Verkäuferin. Weil ich hab dann geguckt, ich hab kein Kleingeld, wie gesagt, ich hab schon gesagt, ich hab kein Kleingeld mehr, ich hatte nur einen 10-Euro-Schein. Und dann hab ich gesagt, habt ihr Wechselgeld? Und dann haben die gesagt, nein, haben wir leider nicht. Ja, das ist natürlich eine gute Antwort auch, wenn man was verkaufen will. Und dann hab ich mir gedacht, okay, was kostet das denn? Da dachte ich mir, für 10 Euro, wie weit komme ich denn? Kaufe ich halt zwei Bücher und ein Bild oder was auch immer. Ach, haben Sie so einen Flohmarkt? So einen Flohmarkt mit Büchern, selbst gemalten Sachen, bemalten Steinen und so, war alles schön dabei. Bemalten, let me dive in there, bemalte Steine. Ja, aber teilweise gar nicht so schön. Mit womit bemalte Steine? Mit Farbe. Wasalte Steine. Let me dive in there. Bemalte Steine.
Ja, aber teilweise gar nicht so schlecht.
Womit bemalte Steine?
Mit Farbe.
Was für Steine?
Ja, Steine aus dem Garten, keine Ahnung.
Relativ flache Steine.
Flache Steine.
Bemalt.
Zum was aufhängen, hinlegen?
Nein, einfach nur zum hinlegen.
Hinlegen.
Darum geht es mir ja nicht.
Dann habe ich gefragt, aha, was kosten denn die Muscheln?
War da so eine Kiste mit Muscheln? Und dann meint die so, die meisten sind kostenlos. Okay, ich werde ein grosses Problem haben, meine 10 Euro loszuwerden. Aber Moment, manche Muscheln sind kostenlos. Die meisten Muscheln sind die meisten. Mir gefällt diese knallharte Hierarchie, die sie Muttern hat am Strand, war Fuerteventura, eine Woche hat Muscheln gesammelt, kommt zurück und die Kids mit so einem knallharten BWL-Blick, die kannst du wegschmeißen, aber die haben... Vor allem, ich dachte mir, wie läuft das jetzt konkret ab? Soll ich jetzt jede einzelne Muschel durchgehen, bis diese irgendwann sagt, ja die kostet fünf Cent? Bei mir geht dann manchmal, was ich super gerne mache bei Online-Shops, ist manchmal auch Spaß, Sortieren nach von teuer bis billig. Finde ich manchmal super spannend, weil es gibt auch so Vinted oder so diese ganzen Secondhand-Mode-Sachen, wo ich jetzt mit einer neuen Farbanalyse will, ich möchte mal neue Shirts gucken, da habe ich mal auch Spaß, weil die meisten Sachen sind aber auch günstig, sehr günstig, irgendwie zwei Euro kriegst du ein gebrauchtes Shirt oder so, dann kannst du aber, habe ich mal auch Spaß, so von teuer nach billig, dann, natürlich stelle ich auch Spaß, da für 30.000 Euro irgendwie ein Muschel rein, aber dann will ich auch wissen, ich habe bei meiner Frage doch gewesen, was ist die teuerste Muschel? Genau, was ist die teuerste Muschel, Was ist die billigste Muschel? Und dann einfach mal gegenüberlegen, wo ist das Spektrum? Da dachte ich mir, okay, da kriegen wir jetzt 10 Euro nicht los. Was haben wir noch? Bemalte Steine. Ich habe direkt den grössten Stein genommen, wirklich wie so ein Handteller grosser Stein. Was kostet der Stein? Ja, 50 Cent. Soll ich jetzt 20 von diesen scheiß Steinen kaufen? Gut, dann nehme ich den schon mal. Ich nehme den grossen Stein. Okay, was haben wir noch? Ja, am besten verkaufen sich die Postkarten.
Postkarten sind ... Sie haben tatsächlich angeboten, die meisten Kunden kauften, sowohl im Land und im Fohlen.
Wer den Stein kaufte, kaufte auch. Die Postkarten waren einfach DIN A4-Blatt durch vier geteilt,IN A6, und dann halt so bemalt, auf der einen Seite ein Bild gemalt, auf der anderen Seite wie als würde es eine Postkarte sein mit den Linien und so. Dann habe ich mir durchgeguckt und habe gesagt, ah, ist das ein Eichhörnchen? Nee, das ist ein Affe. Okay, erstmal unangenehm. Ich finde, du bist jetzt schon zu lange da. Also du bist schon zu lange an diesem Stand mit Kindern. Ich finde so, wenn die Nachbarschaft, da waren schon Väter am Fenster. Weißt du, was ich meine? Ja, ja, das stimmt. Und dann habe ich mir die durchgeguckt und dann dachte ich mir, das muss ich jetzt kaufen, weil sonst ist sie beleidigt, dass ich impliziert habe, dass es ein hässliches Bild ist. Wenn ich sage, ist es ein Eichhörnchen, nee, ist ein Affe, na dann nicht. So, dann ist das Kind traurig, will ich auch nicht, also nehmen wir das schon mal. Dann war ein Bild mit einem Gesicht mit langen Haaren und das war so in der Mitte gespalten und die eine Seite Haare war lila und andere Seite war grau. Und da dachte ich mir, aha, habe ich auch gesagt, ah, zwei Haarfarben. Vergänglichkeit. Und dann hat sie so genickt und dann habe ich gefragt, ah, so gespaltene Persönlichkeit. Und dann hat sie auch genickt. Dann hat sie mir, okay, du nickst einfach alles. Alles klar. Du bist doch die Dümmste hier. Dann habe ich gesagt, was kostet das denn? Ja, zehn Cent. Okay, bei 60 Cent. Ah, weil sie sind fünf Cent. Weil sie sind fünf. Und dann hat sie auch auf einer grossen Liste alles aufgeschrieben, alles addiert. Und dann habe ich auch geguckt, da waren selbstgemachte Bücher dabei. Und die waren ja fantastisch. Selbstgemachte Bücher, wirklich selber getackert, schön Blätter Papier, selber beschrieben mit Coverbild und alles. Und die waren grandios. Und da habe ich richtig zugelangt, da habe ich einige gekauft. Wie teuer waren die denn? Und dann habe ich gefragt, ah, was kosten die denn? Ah, ein Euro. Und dann sagt ein anderes Mädchen, ah nee, die auch nur 50 Cent. Und man denkt, Leute, ihr müsst als Team schon zusammenziehen. Also entweder ist es die Verkaufsstrategie, zu sagen, ein Euro, nee, 50 Cent, ah, so billig. Oder hier fällt jemand im Rücken, weil auch nicht klar ist, wer die Chefin von diesem Verkauf ist. Es gab interne Machtspiele, Machtrangeleien. Absolut, ja. und da wollte jemand offensichtlich den anderen untergraben. Auf der anderen Seite denke ich mir aber auch, wenn jemand vor dir steht und sagt, wie komme ich hier auf fucking 10 Euro, auch ein spannendes Game. Vielleicht wollten die auch einfach dich verarschen. Aber wenn ein Buch selber gemalt, ein Buch sich eine Geschichte auswirkt, der künstlerische Wert. Da ist für dich deine Aufgabe, als Künstler, wäre deine Aufgabe, zu sagen, ihr verkauft euch unter Wert. Egal, was viel Schundliteratur das ist, ihr habt da lange dran gesessen, ihr habt es gemalt, ihr habt es getackert, da ist so viel Wert und künstlerischer Wert reingeflossen, Schöpfungshöhe, ihr könnt das nicht nur für Fultistent verkaufen. Das Ding ist, ich hatte Angst, denen zu vermitteln, dass mir ihr Zeug scheißegal ist, ich will es eh nur kaufen, weil die haben das selber gemacht. Bei Gummibärchen wäre es egal gewesen, wenn da die Eltern sagen, komm, ich gebe dir einfach zwei Euro, scheißegal, schmeißt die Gummibärchen weg, dann denke ich mir, okay, aber wenn die es selber gemacht haben, dachte ich, ich will deren Stolz, weil vielleicht will die mal Autorin sein oder Bilder malen oder so, vielleicht will die hier schon mal unterstützen. Und die Bücher waren so geil. So geil. Ich habe so viele Bücher gekauft und ich lese jeden Tag eins von diesen Büchern, weil die so geil sind. Weil die Bücher sind so toll. Es sind in der Regel einfach sechs, die in der vier Seiten, die in der Mitte zusammengetackert sind und dann zusammengefaltet. Mit ausgedachten Geschichten. Mit ausgedachten Geschichten und das Schema ist immer gleich, weil man merkt relativ schnell, dass ungefähr um die Mitte des Hefts die Ideen und oder die Lust ausgeht, weil die letzten Seiten sind immer weiß, weil die ja committed sich am Anfang auf sechs Seiten und sie hat Ideen vielleicht für zweieinhalb.
Und deswegen, irgendwann fizzelt es immer so aus, irgendwann wird auch keine Farbe mehr benutzt, das Cover ist immer super, Cover ist Farbe und alles wunderbar und Sticker und dann irgendwann Bleistift Kuli und am Ende stehen nur noch Worte.
Einfach so, hey, hey, hey.
Wie die meiste deutsche Literatur.
Wie die meiste Zeit gehört sich der Literatur.
Und dann geht es halt einfach irgendwie aus.
Ein Buch, das
Entdeckungsbuch mit einem
Entdeckungsszenario
pro Seite, also verschiedene Welten,
verschiedene Bereiche, Kosmos. Erster Bereich, Reise in den Weltraum. Ja, und dann sieht man natürlich Sterne, NASA, Rakete, Planeten. NASA-Rakete. NASA-Rakete, auch ein Spannendes politisches Signal. Ja, westlicher Bereich, Distanz zu Russland ist gewahrt. Was ist das zweite Setting? Also wir haben immer Reise. Erstes ist Reise in den Weltraum, zweites ist, was würdest du schätzen? Jetzt in so einer kindlichen Fantasie verschiedene Settings, verschiedene Orte, Weltraum. Ich bin jetzt sowas wie Dinos oder so, also Zeitreise sogar. Reise in die Vergangenheit. Okay, zweites Setting ist Reise unters Meer. Unters Meer? Reise unters Meer, fand ich auch super. Also Meerwelt, Sterns, äh, Sterns, äh, Seestern, Qualle und so. Was ist das dritte Setting? Also wir haben Reise in den Weltraum, Reise unters Meer. Ja, jetzt wie in den Dschungel. Reise in die Unterwelt.
Hölle, also Flammen, Teufel, Dämonen und drei leere Seitenfolgen.
Und das ist das Ende.
Himmel nicht auf dem Plan gewesen.
Fand ich mega geil.
Entdeckungsbuch fand ich schon mal richtig geil.
Horrorfilm-Idee?
Ja.
Du, Typ du, so ein schludriger, müder, kerlöscher Nachbarschaft. Schludrig und müde, das sind die ersten Begriffe, die dir einfallen. So ein loder, verlodderter Typ, läuft so durch die Nacht, mies gelaunt, schlecht gelaunt, unaufmerkst durch die Nachbarschaft, nee, kommt an den Stand und kauft das Buch, die Geschichte, die du erzählt hast, setzt sich zu Hause hin und liest es und es ist so eine Geschichte und es fängt irgendwie süss an, über ein Mädchen, was einen Stand aufmacht und er hat das verkauft und dann führst du so um und siehst so eine Figur, so strichmännische Figur, die so aussieht wie du. Auch verlottert und schäbig.
Die aber an dem Stand steht und was kaufen will.
Und dann geht es weiter.
Der Mann, der gerade noch am Stand war, liest das Buch.
Weiter geht es.
Er liegt abends im Bett.
Wer steht am Fenster?
Das kleine Mädchen.
Du liest das Buch weg, guckst zum Fenster, ein kleiner Kopf, versteckt sich,
reskelndet, leere Seiten,
und dann fliege ich und abspann.
Aber davor noch 20 Sekunden weiss, einfach nur so leere Seiten.
Zehn Euro können sich das Laien bei Amazon.
Aber auch eine sehr, sehr gute Idee
fand ich das Stickerbuch.
Das Stickerbuch ist eine Buchidee, du hast
am Anfang einen Blatt Sticker mit verschiedenen Tieren drauf und dann hast du eine Geschichte mit Leerstellen. Und da musst du immer die Sticker einkleben. Du selber? Du selber. Also du sagst so, im Wald, ich habe einen buschigen Schwanz und ich lebe in einem Bau, ich bin ein Leer. Und dann musst du den richtigen Sticker finden. Und ich dachte mir, das ist ja so eine gute Idee für ein interaktives Kinderbuch. Weil Dinge irgendwo einkleben, macht immer Spaß. Wir alle hatten Stickeralben mit Simpsons, Star Wars, Fussball oder was auch immer. Und da zu sagen, du musst auch noch mitdenken und musst gucken, oh, wenn ich jetzt den Fuchs hier einklebe, habe ich vielleicht hinten nichts mehr, muss ich den dann wegknibbeln und so, habe ich einen Wolf, einen Baum, verschiedene Sachen und sie ist ja kreativ auch gefordert, weil sie hat ja schon dieses Stickerblatt aus irgendeinem... Sie macht das zu Doku. Und sie muss jetzt überlegen, wie kriege ich jetzt all diese Begriffe unter, was ja einfach eine kreative Aufgabe ist. Also du hast hier deine Stichworte. Super stark. Super stark. Fand ich eine richtig, richtig geile Idee. Umsetzung auch 10 von 10? Umsetzung 10 von 10. Ich hab also alle Bücher gekauft und dann, ja okay, addier mal, dann hat sie quänt lang addiert, 50 Cent plus 50 Cent, plus 50 Cent, plus 50 Cent, plus 50 Cent, sehe ich ein, das konnte man toll tief. Plus 50 Cent, sie hat so eine ganz lange Liste auf ihrem Zettel, da steht, hat sie da wirklich und dann dann hat man wirklich gesehen, wie sie mit dem Finger immer runter und dann aber wieder ganz nach oben gegangen ist. Und ich dachte mir, okay, das dauert noch ein bisschen. Und dann 50 Cent und dann waren wir aber bei 5 Euro und dann habe ich gesagt, okay, pass auf, wir machen folgendes, das wird nichts mehr. Ich gebe euch 10 Euro und dafür kriege ich einen Gutschein für einen Laden. Und wenn ihr beim nächsten Mal wieder verkauft, dann habe ich 5 Euro Guthaben quasi. Und die so, ja, okay, machen wir. Super. Und dann habe ich gesagt, okay, wir brauchen, da hat sie geschrieben, Gutschein für fünf Euro mit Datum und dann müssen alle unterschreiben. Alle, die dabei waren. Ich musste unterschreiben und die waren drei Mädchen und ein Junge und dann habe ich gesagt, okay, ihr müsst auch alle unterschreiben als Zeugen quasi, die das dann beglaubigen können. Stark. Und dann meinten die Mädchen nur so, ah, nee, er nicht, er gehört gar nicht wirklich dazu, er hängt nur die Werbung für uns auf, er ist nur Minion. Er ist nur Minion? Er ist nur Minion. Und das fand ich einen sehr coolen Ausdruck, dass die wirklich in ihrer achtjährigen Welt schon sagen, nee, der ist nur Minion, der arbeitet nur für uns.
Er macht nur die Werbung, er ist nur Minion.
Also ich kenne ganze Branchen,
die jetzt sagen,
ja, also
ich finde, auf eine Art,
nachdem man,
du hast sie ja in die Hand genommen, wolltest sie in 10 Euro
geben, wolltest sie unterstützen, finde ich super schön,
super süss und dann am Ende
nach dieser Odyssee
festzustellen,
dass die
Und die Neuro geben, wo sie unterstützen, finde ich super schön, super süss. Und dann am Ende, nach dieser Odyssee, festzustellen, dass die Arschlöcher sind. Ja, aber ich finde das so geil, dass selbst in so einem achtjährigen Kopf wird unterschieden zwischen Angestellten und Inhabern, dass du sagst, nee, nee, wir drei Mädchen, wir haben den Laden und du arbeitest nur für uns. Also im Endeffekt, dass sie sofort diesen Klassenkampf herstellen und sagen, nee, du bist nur Minion, du arbeitest für uns, für uns und wir ernten quasi alles und nur wir unterschreiben, nur wir drei sind wirklich berechtigt, dieses offizielle Dokument, dieses Gutschein, genau zu unterschreiben, du hast kein Recht, deine Stimme ist nicht nötig, um diesen offiziellen Akt hier zu begehen. Fand ich so, und vor allem auch in dieser Sprache, in dieser Kindersprache, zu sagen, er ist nur Minion, fand ich wirklich fantastisch. Weil ich dachte mir so, passt mal auf, in welche Welt ihr hier reinwachst, am Ende seid ihr alle Minions. Ihr seid alle meine Minions. Ja, ich fand das richtig fantastisch. Erstmal muss ich doch sagen, großes Lob an dich, du hast es ganz toll gehandelt. Ich mag das. Ich finde das super, ich finde auch mit dem Gutschein, das war eine ganz, ganz tolle Idee, damit die keine Probleme haben mit Selbstwert oder checken, die Preise, die wir gegeben haben, werden auch ernst genommen und so. Generell werden sie als Stand ernst genommen und dieser Gutschein war da glaube ich die beste Entscheidung. Ich finde es noch besser und fragwürdig, wenn du den jetzt auch einlöst. Ich versuche den jetzt halt immer dabei zu haben, damit, wenn ich die wiedersehe, dass ich dann nicht, oh, ich habe meinen Gutschein vergessen, sondern dass ich dann sagen kann, so, ihr habt hier alle unterschrieben, jetzt kriege ich was, weil ich weiß nicht, aber dann stell dich mir vor, Ding Dong bei dir an der Tür, du machst auf, Vater. So, Vater sagt so, okay, ich hab Dokumente, ich hab Dokumente. Entschuldigung, meine Tochter hat gesagt, sie kam vorbei, die sind Gutschein dabei. Sind sie Vater der Inhaberin oder Vater des Minions? Wie, nein, also ich bin der Vater von Luisa. Ah, alles klar, mit der habe ich einen Vertrag abgeschlossen. Ja, sie haben jetzt, weil die machen ja einen Stand, um sich ein bisschen Taschengeld dazu zu verdienen, süßen Stand da. Und jetzt hat meine Tochter mir gesagt, dass sie mit diesem handgeschriebenen Gutschein bezahlt haben. Ja, natürlich. Den habe ich für fünf Euro erworben beim letzten Mal, den habe ich mit zehn Euro gezahlt und dann haben sie alle unterschrieben, können Sie ja gerne sehen. Hier ist meine Unterschrift. Das kann ja jeder drauf gemalt haben. Erkennen Sie nicht die Unterschrift Ihrer Tochter? Das ist ein Stand von Kindern. Geben die ihm einfach Geld. Die haben zehn Euro gegeben. Was für zehn Euro? Ich habe den zehn Euro einen Gutschein gegeben. Ja, beim letzten Mal. Nein, Sie bezahlen den bei Kindern, die versucht Kinder zu bescheissen. Moment mal. Mit ihrem scheiß Handgeschriebenen Gutschein. Heißt es, Ihre Tochter hat gar nicht vor einem Monat einen Stand gehabt. Und dann hinten am Fenster der kleine Kopf abspannen. Ja. Also finde ich ganz schon k Post-Credit-Scene. Ja, das ist nicht mal der Film. Die Post-Credit-Scene ist länger als der Film. Die Post-Credit-Scene ist besser als mancher kompletter Film und das ist nur das Endstück. Nice. Und sehr, sehr schön. Und ich glaube, das hat einen Trend losgetreten. Und das fand ich sehr, sehr sympathischisch, war ich auch wieder spazieren unterwegs und da stand auch ein Stand mit Kindern, aber nicht mal kleiner. Was ist das für eine Nachbarschaft? Du wurdest in Springfield, in Nebraska. Die brauchen Geld, die Kinder brauchen Geld, die haben kein Geld mehr, Kinderarmut steigt leider. Die brauchen Geld, die brauchen Cash. Aber dass du in so einer Nachbarschaft lebst, wo die ganze Zeit so Lemonade-Stands sind, finde ich ja absolut geil. Ich finde das super. Gibt es bei mir nicht. Und dann war da auch so ein Stand von kleinen, die waren ein, zwei Jahre jünger, also noch ein gutes Stück jünger, die hatten da auch ihren Stand. Klassische Minions. Und dann bin ich gekommen und als die mich gesehen haben, haben die sich versteckt. Ah ja. Und das fand ich so geil. Relatable. Das fand ich so relatable. Ja klar, als Kind, du hast Bock, okay, ja geil, wir verdienen Geld und ah, die Spielsachen, damit spiele ich nicht mehr.
Und dann kommt aber wirklich ein Kunde und dann versteckst du dich.
Und dann bin ich vorbeigelaufen und dann kamen sie wieder langsam raus.
Und ich dachte mir, die haben jetzt diesen Stand gebaut und verstecken sich vor ihren Kunden.
Und ich dachte mir, ja, das ist es doch. Ja, yes, yes, yes. Und solche möchte ich in Klamotten leben, möchte ich Leute haben.
Genau, das sind die, eigentlich, das ist für Service, das ist nämlich immer unsere Serviceecke.
Für Leute, die verkaufen, versteckt euch vor den Kunden. Das ist unsere. Das ist unsere Serviceecke. Ja, weil die ist halt relativ simpel und gemacht und relativ schlecht. Normalerweise ich in jeder Folge im Podcast sagen will, wie wir behandelt werden wollen. Nee, weil genau, das ist ja, ich liebe ja auch Baumärkte, weil da wirklich so no bullshit Leute arbeiten, die sich nicht, die die haben anscheinend richtig viel zu tun immer, weil die haben keinen Bock auf dich. Du fragst sie was und die fahren im Gabelstapler weg von dir, während du sie was fragst. Weil ich denke mir, was macht ihr, ist ja Geschäft, also was, weil die haben alle so viel zu tun und ich glaube auch, dass sie viel zu tun haben, ich habe das Gefühl, alle sind auch sehr ermüdet von von dem Publikum, was da auftritt. Und ich glaube, der Laden würde gut funktionieren. Also da wären Gewusel, da würden Dinge von einem auch immer mehr. Wenn da niemand einkaufen würde. Die würden eine Million Schrauben verkaufen pro Tag. Kein Kunde da. Ich glaube, die würden trotzdem rumwuseln. Ich glaube, die wuseln auch am Sonntag rum. Also wenn du da, wenn die geschlossen sind und du schaust rein, wuseln die trotzdem rum und machen die Dinge. Ah, okay, warte mal, Verschluss die ganze Zeit um den Zentimeter. Na, Moment mal, passt das überhaupt rein? Das ist schon gut. Und dann gibt es immer so die eine Person an diesem Farbenrührer, an dieser Farbenrührer-Titel. Habe ich noch nie gesehen. Musste ich einmal machen, weil ich habe einmal in Berlin, wollte ich bei der Frank-Elstner-Masterclass ein Greenscreen haben und normalerweise würde man sagen, okay, dann kauf dir ein Greenscreen, den du so auf den Boden stellst und dann so aufziehst, wie so eine grosse Leinwand. Und dann verschwindest. Und dann kann man die wieder einpacken und woanders enttragen. Ich bin zum Baumarkt gefahren, habe mir diese perfekte Greenscreen-Chroma-Farbe mischen lassen und habe damit die komplette Wand gestrichen. Die besteht aus grün, etwas
hellerem grün, etwas dunkleren grün
und orange. Kann man sich
tippen? Wenn du dunkles
grün, helles grün und mittleres grün
brauchst,
meines Erachtens, aber bin ich Laie,
würde ich oben und unten
kürzen, weil dann ergibt
sie das Grün. Dann bist du offensichtlich
Laie. Es gibt auch sowas wie Farbobertöne.
Ich glaube, du wurdest verarscht.
Das kann auch sein, ja. Also wenn man das perfekte
Du bist der Welt. Weil dann ergibt sich das Grün. Dann ist es aber offensichtlich Leih. Es gibt auch so etwas wie Farbobertöne. Ich glaube, du wurdest verarscht. Das kann auch sein, ja. Also wenn man das perfekte Grün war, schon so aussieht wie die Leinwand. Und dann machen sie es ein bisschen dunkler und dann machen sie es wieder ein bisschen heller. Ja. Und dann in Frank-Edster-Masterclass, da war auch ein Dozent. Und der hat ab und zu mal so, der war Manager von Promi-Manager. Ach, da gab es auch Dozenten. Ja, ja, der war Promi-Manager. Ich dachte, der hat da nur Quatsch gemacht. Nee, nee. Der war Promi-Manager, also von vielen berühmten Leuten. und der hat ab und zu mal so, der war Manager von Promi-Manager. Ach, da gab es auch Dozenten. Ja, ja, ja, der war Promi-Manager. Ich dachte, der hat nur Quatsch gemacht. Nee, nee. Der war Promi-Manager, also von vielen berühmten Leuten und der hat dann erzählt, was macht man mit den ersten Millionen und so, so Zeug. Und wir sassen im Offen Mund da und dachten uns, das ist unsere Zukunft, nichts davon habe ich jemals gebraucht. Und der hat irgendwann einen Daumen verloren. Während der Zeit der Masterklasse? Ja. Und dann haben wir uns überlegt, wir schicken dem eine Videonachricht im Sinne von
sorry,
gute Besserung, was auch immer,
und dafür haben wir unsere Daumen alle in diese
grüne Farbe getunkt
und haben dann vor dem Greenscreen so
Thumbs up
gemacht
und da haben wir nochmal die grüne Farbe gebraucht.
Und da hast du den Vorteil, das kannst du mit
so einem Aufbau-Greenscreen nicht, sondern
du kannst es eintun. Du hast dann die perfekte Farbe
Aber gemacht. Und da haben wir nochmal die grüne Farbe gebraucht. Und da hast du den Vorteil, das kannst du mit so einem Aufbau-Greens-Green nicht,
sondern du kannst es eintrungen.
Du hast dann die perfekte Farbe zum Hintergrund,
alle haben dann grünen Daumen
und dann sagt mal
eine Naturschutzmädel, die an der Tür steht,
sagt, nee, ich kann nicht
für die Umwelt bezahlen,
aber sie haben wortwörtlich
einen grünen Daumen.
Bam, bam, bam,
Ja, stimmt, vielleicht bin ich jetzt auch in so einer Sekte drin.
Ich habe auch bei diesen Unterschriften und Sachen immer das Gefühl, ich hoffe, das ist keine Sekte.
Weil es gibt ja so viele Natursekten, auch so Anastasia und so und Gedöns, wo du dann halt über dieses Naturschutz-Hippie-Ding und dann plötzlich bist du in irgendeinem Raumschiff oder so und du gerettest. Natursekten ist was anderes. Hast du die Klammer wieder zu unserem Pornospritzigen, Erotik? Porn, Sex Talk, Sex Talk, wie sagt man, Exclusive? Ne, was ist? Explicit. Jetzt müssen wir es wir es wieder explicit machen, Stefan. Ich komme immer rein und denke, ich erzähle ein paar süße Geschichten über Kinder aus der Nachbarschaft und du wieder explicit. Ach, schade. Na gut. Stefan, Sex-Ecke bald bi-weekly hier. Schade. Ja, schickt uns gerne eure Service-Vorschläge, wirklich. Ich fände sie uns gerne an florentin.at zentralemis.podcast.com. Nein, schreibt uns per Instagram oder Reddit oder so. Oder auf unserer Website, das podcast.com. Da könnt ihr unten in die, könnt ihr unten in das Feld. Bindet sich per Mail. Doch, da haben wir extra so ein Feldprogramm programmiert. Wenn du jetzt immer sagst, nicht da einschreiben, dann werden wir nie herausfinden. Lass es an deine Website gehen, an deine E-Mail. An meine Website. Ja, steffatürzel.com, als ob die nicht offline wäre. So viel Werbung wie da drauf ist, machst du ja ganz schön viel Geld. Nee, ich glaube, nicht so viel. Also, genau, okay, schickt uns das, wenn ihr im Service arbeitet, man mit euch, genau, wenn ihr mit Menschen arbeitet. Ja, und wenn ihr kein Blatt vor den Mund nehmt, bitte, ich will ja keine Blätter vor Mündern sehen. Ihr arbeitet Menschen und läuft kein Blatt vor dem Mund, meldet euch, weil dann haben wir ein paar Fragen an euch, wenn ihr Bock hättet, hier drin vorzukommen, haben wir ein paar Fragen an euch, ich telefoniere kurz, das ist die neue Rubrik Florentins Service-Ecke. Ansonsten vielen Dank, dass ich da sein durfte, überhaupt, dass ich zu Wort gekommen bin. Ja, vielen Dank, Stefan Tietze, dass du Zeit hattest, Dankeschön, Stefan Tietze.
Ich bin gestaunt, wer nächste Woche mit dabei ist und ansonsten wünsche ich euch noch eine schöne Woche.
Haut rein, geniesst den Sommer, macht's gut.
Tschüss, bis zum nächsten Mal wieder. Macht's gut, tschau. Worst Bird Production?